this episode is brought to you by
shopify shopify is one of my favorite
companies out there one of my favorite
platforms ever
and let's get into it shopify is a
platform as i mentioned designed for
anyone to sell anything anywhere giving
entrepreneurs the resources once
reserved for big business so what does
that mean that means in no time flat you
can have a great looking online store
that brings your ideas products and so
on to life and you can have the tools to
manage your day-to-day business and
drive sales this is all possible without
any coding or design experience
whatsoever shopify instantly lets you
accept all major payment methods shopify
is thousands of integrations and
third-party apps from on-demand printing
to accounting to advanced chat bots
anything you can imagine they probably
have a way to plug and play and make it
happen shopify is what i wish i had had
when i was venturing into e-commerce way
back in the early 2000s what they've
done is pretty remarkable i first met
the founder toby in 2008 when i became
an advisor and it's been spectacular
i've loved watching shopify go from
roughly 10 to 15 employees at the time
to 7 000 plus today serving customers in
175 countries with total sales on the
platform exceeding 400 billion dollars
what does that really mean that means
every 28 seconds more or less a small
business owner makes their first sale on
shopify more people in more places
of all ages every single day they power
millions of entrepreneurs from their
first sale all the way to full scale and
you would recognize a lot of large
companies that also use them who started
small so get started by building and
customizing your online store again with
no coding or design experience required
access powerful tools to help you find
customers drive sales and manage your
day-to-day gain knowledge and confidence
with extensive resources to help you
succeed and i've actually been involved
with some of that way back in the day
which was awesome the build a business
competition and other things plus with
24 7 support you're never alone and
let's face it being an entrepreneur can
be lonely but you have support you have
resources you don't need to feel alone
in this case more than a store shopify
grows with you and they never stop
innovating providing more and more tools
to make your business better and your
life easier go to shopify.com
tim that's
s-h-o-p-i-f-y dot com slash tim all
lowercase for a free 14-day trial and
get full access to shopify's entire
suite of features start selling on
shopify today go to shopify.com
tim right now and check it out they have
a lot to offer shopify.com
tim
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance i recommended it
in fact in the four-hour body this is
more than ten years ago and i did not
get paid to do so with approximately 75
vitamins minerals and whole foods
sourced ingredients you'd be very hard
pressed to find a more nutrient-dense
and comprehensive formula on the market
it has multi-vitamins multi-mineral
greens complex probiotics and prebiotics
for gut health and immunity formula
digestive enzymes adaptogens and much
more i usually take it once or twice a
day just to make sure i've covered my
bases if i miss anything i'm not aware
of of course i focus on nutrient-dense
meals to begin with that's the basis but
athletic greens makes it easy to get a
lot of nutrition when whole foods aren't
readily available from travel packets i
always have them in my bag when i'm
zipping around right now athletic greens
is giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake can i answer your personal
questions
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal and personality
[Music]
why don't you just tell me what you got
for breakfast as a starting point what
do you for breakfast i had these amazing
scrambled eggs
and sausage
and fruit
and orange juice
sounds like a very complete
breakfast it was very complete except
it's missing the coffee i love coffee
but i'm not drinking coffee right now
because it was interfering with my sleep
let's just talk about that for a second
so
caffeine sleep sleep is my number one
priority right now yeah
how did you end up
removing caffeine because that can be
sometimes difficult you just go cold
turkey i just went cold turkey i was
only drinking a cup of coffee
with breakfast in the morning maybe a
cup of decaf in the afternoon yeah but
then
i was having trouble sleeping the last
few months and i kept thinking it was
just kind of stress and nerves around
the book launch and all the stuff this
uncharted territory and then finally
about eight days ago i was like maybe
it's caffeine let me just not have
coffee today
and that night
i slept so hard i drooled on my pillow
one cup yeah
that was it and i think it affects
different people differently right yeah
it does and i have genetically
a predisposition or i suppose it's kind
of a determinism to
caffeine fast metabolism so i clear it
or i used to clear it very quickly but
as you age
your ability to clear it i suppose
through the liver and through other
means
diminishes so in effect the half-life of
caffeine gets longer as you get older so
i've been coming to the same conclusion
i'm reading
why we sleep i think it is by matt
walker right now
and he mentioned this and i've been
progressively
cutting back on caffeine but god damn do
i love stimulants it's hard well i love
i love coffee so the second night
i slept so deeply it was like
disorienting i woke up in the middle of
the night i felt like i was drowning in
the ocean and i was like no
don't don't send me back back there and
then i fell asleep again and i've just
been sleeping like a baby for the last
week all right and i did this once
before i went a whole year
but then i started drinking coffee again
you went a whole year without coffee
yeah
wow
incredible control well i can stay off
the caffeine wagon for a few weeks at a
time okay and then i develop a tolerance
so quickly once i have one cup
what will generally happen is i'm having
it in say a restaurant if i have it in a
coffee shop it's safer because you have
to pay for the second cup
in a restaurant you just keep going the
endless cup of coffee phenomenon starts
to manifest and then i've had three cups
and then before i know it
if i have a day without caffeine i just
feel like i'm asleep on my feet
right because caffeine
blocks i shouldn't say in effect like
blocks adenosine which builds up over
time in your system and creates this
sleep pressure yes and it uh i think
it's an antagonist or it might be
it actually occupies the receptor that
adenosine is did you read michael
pollan's latest book i think so i
believe so this would have been this is
your mind on plants morphine caffeine
and mescaline that's right yeah yes yeah
yeah he talks right then yeah it's great
any aversion to me mentioning other
books authors anything like that no
please do please do so let's let's set
some context here yeah let's do it and
we might just start the interview with
what we're just we're just going to get
a rolling start here yeah this is like
the california roll uh as the police
officer once told me the non-stop stop
at a stop sign we're just gonna take
down to five i don't recommend this
folks talk to your local law enforcement
before you try anything like that my
guest today jason portnoy nice to see
you and we are here in beautiful austin
texas at the moment who is jason
entrepreneur venture capitalist and
author jason portner began his career at
paypal working closely with technology
icons like peter thiel elon musk max
levchin and reid hoffman he served as
the first chief financial officer aka
cfo of palantir technologies and later
founded oakhouse partners a top
performing venture capital firm jason is
sought after as a trusted advisor to
technology company ceos and has spoken
on topics ranging from executive
leadership to the intersections of
technology and humanity he holds
engineering degrees from both stanford
university
ms and the university of colorado that
is bs not bs's and you guys should know
what i mean by now his new book which we
will get to
is silicon valley porn star what a title
and we will certainly delve into
the the origins of that but let's start
with the basics first just paint a
picture and this is the kind of boring
foundational work for this interview but
you're gonna have to do a lot of this
stuff in other interviews so you might
as well get some practice in sure
where'd you grow up
basics of the family just the connective
tissue of of childhood maybe just a
little bit of that to get us started i
grew up in the suburbs of new jersey a
town called hillsboro new jersey my
parents both worked i had a sister or
still have a sister who's about five
years older than me
we had a couple cats a family dog it was
pretty kind of quintessential suburban
life there's sidewalks on the street i
played with my friends on the street we
had a pool in the backyard
it was great what did your parents do
professionally they were both chemists
interestingly
chemists
and did you follow in those footsteps i
did when i went off to college i didn't
really know exactly what i wanted to do
but i liked chemistry and i liked math
and my dad suggested why don't you do
chemical engineering because it will be
a blending of those two things
and so i said great actually then i
looked up on a table of starting
salaries for different majors and at the
time chemical engineers made the highest
starting salary of any major in college
and i said that's perfect sounds good
sign me up
for those who don't know what does a
chemical engineer do
and what is chemical engineering i would
be lying if i said i knew exactly
because i never worked as a chemical
engineer so i studied it when i was
studying that in college a lot of it was
around
things in the oil and gas industry
and so i think at a high level you could
say
a chemist might figure something out in
a laboratory some kind of chemical
process and then a chemical engineer
might be responsible for
figuring out how to mass produce that
thing so a chemist maybe makes a little
bit in a vial but how do you make tons
and tons and tons of this stuff it's
actually really challenging because you
have
heat and thermal dynamics and all kinds
of stuff like that i'd imagine with the
energy sector and hydrocarbon
industries in texas they're probably a
lot of chemical engineers in texas a lot
yes there must be
when did you diverge from your
pre-ordained
high-paying career as a
chemical engineer
well it probably started in college when
i was an undergrad i was at university
of colorado at boulder and at some point
my dad always giving me suggestions on
what to study said maybe you should get
a minor in business so you at least
learn the basics and
the minor in business that i got was
like one accounting class one finance
class one macro economics class one
microeconomics class and so on and so
forth
and
then
when i went off to grad school if you
think about
what i had studied as an undergrad i had
chemistry math and now business and i
liked the intersection of the math and
the business more than i liked the
intersection of the other any other
things and so i got a master's degree at
stanford in a field that was really a
combination of math and business what is
the old like orf orf no
so different schools called by different
names sometimes you'll hear operations
research
sometimes you'll hear industrial
engineering a lot of times those
departments are combined so it'll be
ieor industrial engineering and
operations research stanford's
department i forget the name when i
first got there but the name changed to
management science and engineering and
so my that's why technically my degree
is in and you went straight from
undergrad to grad school i did all right
what was your thinking behind that what
was the at least tentative plan or hope
or
thinking if any behind that
i just thought that's what everyone did
i didn't know that there was any i
didn't know that there was any other way
my parents had all gone to graduate
school and they had gone directly after
undergrad and i just thought that's what
you did that's what someone does yeah
and i actually i really had tried to get
into a phd program i thought that that
was
my destiny
and i didn't
and i was really upset about that and
for the first year when i was in
graduate school i was trying so hard to
get into the phd program and i couldn't
and looking back i think it's probably a
good thing i think the life of a phd
researcher probably wouldn't have suited
me
as well as as the direction i've gone in
i had a
friend of mine on a long time ago on the
podcast named mike maples mike maples jr
oh yeah who was the first person to
introduce me to angel investing and
explain and some
respect how the basics were he's a good
teacher
yeah i owe mike a lot
and
i remember i think it was mike who said
on the podcast
sorry mike if i'm misquoting him but
it's pretty good quote so you can take
the half credit anyway he said something
like sometimes we need
life to save us from what we want right
and that might be an example of that
absolutely so you didn't get into this
phd program
there you are at stanford
what are some of the more formative
things or
impactful
occasions that come about while you're
at
at stanford so i went directly from
undergrad but what i found was most of
my classmates had not
so a lot of them had gone
and had some kind of prior work
experience before coming to grad school
consulting was a big one investment
banking was a big one some of them had
family businesses that they helped run
now are these people in your program are
they people who are at the graduate
school of business gsb both both so the
program that i was in had classes
co-listed with the gsb
so i was sometimes attending classes in
the gsb and sometimes you had gsb
students in our classes got it and
a lot of these people had some prior
work experience and
after a while after a few months in
school i realized it was really helpful
for them because they could
contextualize the things that we were
learning and whereas for me it was all
very abstract and so i decided i wanted
to get a job and
that if i should continue like that
discontinue i get pretty bored
interviewing myself well actually there
was there was a
there was a career fair around that time
so this was just to set the stage i
guess it was late 1999
the dot-com boom is in full swing
all these companies have tons of capital
from sandhill road venture capital
investors
and they're hiring like crazy and
they're on stanford's campus so there's
a career fair there's a guy running
around in a dog costume i think the
company was called fog dog
i thought it was hilarious and i really
wanted to work there
so until i got that worked the dog
outfit worked so i applied there
didn't get a job there so maybe again
life sending me
the right things i don't know
shortly after that i submitted my resume
to a company that was advertising in a
newsletter
called confinity and then i got invited
in for a job interview and that company
later turned into paypal so let's talk
about this job interview
oh yeah let me shake out my notes here
we go
perfect segue so you interviewed with
the ceo of confinity i'm going to read
this literally who hired you because
you're reading list or at least
partially that was a factor so who was
that ceo what was the company at the
time right what did it do and
most interesting to me perhaps
is the reading list i'd love to know
what was on the reading list well you
jokingly said i got hired because of the
reading list but he later joked that i
got hired because i wore a company
t-shirt to the interview oh no
very good-natured uh joke
so
the company was called confinity
it was a company that had been started
by
peter thiel and max levchin
and the intention was to allow people to
be money to each other on their palm
pilots that was the way the product
worked i guess the intention was
it was really the beginning of a
cryptographic currency
because they were going to
digitize currency make it easy to
transfer money all around the world very
frictionless all of that stuff was way
over my head at the time my first
interview was with peter at a hobie's
restaurant in palo alto california yes
just for those who don't know so hobies
back in the day
was a famous
meeting place famous deal-making
there are a handful of these
and there's one in woodside also you
know the handful of these spots but
hobies is bringing back the memories
sorry to interrupt that's okay that is
where mike and i used to meet for
lunch to talk about this kind of there
you go so wow hobies haven't thought
about that all right so you guys meet a
host so we meet at hobies i'm wearing
the company t-shirt that i got from a
buddy on campus
he thinks that's pretty hilarious
and he's telling me all about his
background and confinity's plans
and again a lot of it's going over my
head but
it sounds very cool and very interesting
and he's very nice and then i casually
mentioned that i had traveled around
europe the prior summer with my
girlfriend and i had taken a backpack
full of books to read and then he's like
well what were the books
and then that's all we talked about for
the entire interview was
what books i had read what did i learn
from them what was interesting from them
what were some of the books i think one
was of mice and men there was a bunch of
hemingway books i remember that
i remember
i read the art of war
i remember i read the dao de ching
so there's a pretty eclectic mix of
different things that i had just
accumulated people said oh you should
read this book oh you should read this
book and i had a list of them and before
i left for my trip i went to a used
bookstore and bought a whole bunch of
them
it's an eclectic
portfolio of books yeah it was it was it
was interesting a lot of train rides in
europe yeah
of the books and the train rides was
there any particular at that point in
your life that had
stuck with you for any particular reason
or that was memorable the hemingway
books really
stuck with me for a while i can't recall
exactly why because it's been some time
but maybe just the imagery the way he
was writing what he was writing about
like both fighting in spain and things
it was really and i was probably reading
that while i was on a train in spain
totally so there was something about
that whole thing the art of war was
definitely kind of fascinating as well
there were others i'm sorry i can't
remember no that's fine hemingway i'm
just getting
about to step back into hemingway after
a hiatus of 10 plus years
for a whole bunch of reasons i'm going
to be spending more time in africa and
want to read a number of his books but
he's one of these sort of victims of his
own success i mean in more ways than one
certainly but you know it's he became so
popular that he became unfashionable
among critics but he also won the nobel
prize
for literature right
he was really really good
in so many respects and then got widely
copied so it seemed less unique maybe
once factoring in the many copycats
who followed but at the time
incredible storyteller and certainly
maybe better modeled as a writer than as
a lifestyle sure potentially you know
the newsletter i just want to piece
together a few things so you you get an
email about this job opening yes so i'm
part of something called basis it's the
business association of stanford
engineering students they have a one
credit or i'm pretty sure is one credit
seminar on friday afternoons where they
bring in speakers from
silicon valley mostly business leaders
so i signed up to get this one credit
and i was attending these you know
friday afternoon lectures essentially
and then there's a mailing list
associated with that and so that's where
i got this
what was the job position financial
analyst financial analyst yes all right
so you ended up how were you notified
that you got this job so i have my
breakfast with peter we talk about the
book i jokingly say i must have read the
right books because i get an email later
that day hey great news we'd like you to
come in for some additional interviews
so i go in i don't know a few days later
i meet with a lot more people on the
team
and then i get hired and i start working
there january 3rd of 2000
so this interviewing stuff happened in
december i start working in january i
mean i have some fun stories from back
then well i like fun stories
well one of the funny things so
back then people could
add money to their paypal account in
different ways you could use a credit
card you could use a
check you could do the bank transfer and
you could get your money out of paypal
in those same ways and so some back then
a lot of stuff was still manual so
at the end of the week i would get a
list spit out on a printer
of checks that we had to write and i
would go and i would type each one into
quickbooks
and type in
you know the name of the account how
much money
we had one printer in the office so i'd
have to go load the checks into the
printer call the cfo on his desk phone
maybe cell phone
and tell him to hit print
then he would sign them all by hand
and then i would stuff them in envelopes
and send them out
wow
yeah so that was those was very early
days we had i think when i started we
had about 14 000 paypal users that's
incredible it was crazy do you have any
idea i don't but do you have any
guesstimate for
at the end of your tenure how many users
there were or even now how many users
there are do you have any ideas i don't
remember at this point it has to be
hundreds of millions it's a lot yeah
it's a lot it's a big number
this makes me want to recommend to folks
reading
the first episode ever of masters of
scale
with reid hoffman who also plays a role
in absolutely in this whole story
where he interviews brian chesky and
they talk about
doing things that don't scale
in the beginning
that was something that didn't scale
yeah doing a lot of things in the
beginning that don't scale yeah
and
i'll leave it to people to listen to
that but you are in the office at that
time
who else is in the office with you
peter's there
max levgen's there there's probably
i think i was employee 34
so i don't want to list off 33 other
people
but names that people would recognize
much like
we read in your in your bio yeah sure
and was read around at the time no so
not yet not yet i don't think reid was
around
yet
and
elon existed
very nearby so he had started a company
called x.com and
that company was in an office also on
university avenue in palo alto but down
the street
and so when i started at paypal the two
companies had not combined yet
so for those who just want to imagine a
visual here so university avenue
is like the downtown strip
in
palo alto i mean strip makes it sound a
lot bigger than it actually is
very beautiful
and if you travel down to one end you're
not that far from palm drive which is
this incredibly picturesque
drive that leads you into stanford
campus with these
immaculate palm trees sort of arching up
over either side with the
rodent
sculpture garden on the right hand side
it's it's truly it's pretty amazing an
incredible sight
yeah uh it's it's about as sort of
stepford wives like truman show as you
can get but it's a beautiful place i
used to spend a lot of time there
what are some of the
lessons you learned or interesting
practices that you observed
with peter
well one of the biggest things i noticed
frankly with
peter certainly with reid also with elon
over time
is that they were never
only doing one thing at a time which i
thought was very interesting because
i would have thought logically oh you're
doing this thing you focus on this thing
and you you do this thing
but for them
and this is now spanning not just when i
started but i was at paypal for about
three years so just kind of spanning
that three-year time frame watching them
they always tended to be doing multiple
things and i feel like they got a lot of
benefit out of doing that because they
would
be
getting exposed to different ideas or
solving different problems or some
meeting different people there was just
all the stuff that they were interacting
with and then they would bring that back
with them into
the paypal office when you say different
types of things or multiple things so it
wouldn't be two paypal specific things
or would it just be two divergent things
within the realm of possible things you
could do and really or could you give an
example well like in peter's case he was
he had been running a
a hedge fund
vc fund prior to paypal starting had met
max
max had this idea
they decided that they were going to
work on it together peter invested money
out of his fund to help launch the thing
and he still had the fund on the side
you know probably wasn't more i
shouldn't even guess what percentage of
his time it wasn't a lot
but
he still had something else that got a
little bit of his attention while he was
building paypal
in reed's case
i don't remember in detail but i mean
even if you just look at elon
today
sure you know he's he has busy boys yeah
super busy well even busier i guess the
last couple weeks but even rewind 10
years if he just had spacex and tesla i
mean those are two
really big creations that he's working
on but i'm i'm sure that he's pulling
from one
you know he's learning things from one
that he's applying to the other and so i
think there's a lot of transfers some
benefit there yeah
you know i read let me just pull this up
here
that peter would give employees titles
and levels of responsibility that
reflected their potential not their
current ability
could you elaborate
you know i was on the receiving end of
that so i was at paypal for about three
years company goes public
then gets acquired by ebay and five or
six of us leave to go help peter start
his hedge fund again so he's gonna use
clarion clarion capital yeah so he's
gonna go back to his fund he renames it
and decides he wants to build this this
is gonna be his next project and so
when i get there this is pretty funny so
i had worked pretty closely with peter
because i was on the i was a financial
analyst and then i was the vice
president of financial planning and
analysis at paypal and so i was working
a lot on the corporate financial model
when the company went public that was
kind of a cornerstone of the ipo
roadshow presentation and i got to go
sit in on some of those meetings which
was really cool
but anyway i got to work really closely
with him and so
when i said i was interested to go over
to clarium i didn't know what a hedge
fund was really and he told me to read
this book called when genius failed
which is about oh it's about long-term
long-term capital management so that was
and then i thought
this is light inspirational yeah just i
was like i don't really know what hedge
funds do he's like go read this book you
know right so i read the book
and i was like okay now i have a rough
idea what hedge funds do and then i
thought i had to read the wall street
journal every morning and i was so
diligent about that for a while it was
and looking back is kind of comical but
i would just i was like this is my
education like this is how i'm going to
do this and so
and then i'm like well what should my
title be he's like well you should be
the cfo i'm like
i don't i don't know anything about this
he was like you'll pick it up quick you
know he had a lot of confidence and
faith and we had worked together for you
know pretty closely for a while by that
point
and so i feel like that's was a good
example you know i think he was he was
thinking where could i be
you know in several years if if we
stayed on some kind of trajectory not
what was my current ability at the time
and is that something you've seen him do
with other people in the sense that it's
something it's
maybe easy for him to give because i'm
just i'm trying to
imagine the thought process behind it
because at least i've only met him a few
times but peter strikes me as a very
deliberate
person in so many ways what do you think
the thought process is behind that is it
that it's easy to give if it doesn't
work out obviously
you know the employment can always be
terminated
so
yeah i don't want to speak too much for
him no because he's not speaking for him
but yeah
well and because i know him is very
thoughtful
i feel like he likes to invest in things
that other people don't realize yet sure
he's very good at it and so he does the
same thing with people
so
he meets a person that's cool he says
that i think this person
has potential that other people don't
see yet
i'm going to take a chance and i'm going
to maybe help cultivate that potential
in them so if you look over the course
of his career he's launched so many
people often different directions in
different things and i think that's why
and it could be there's a lot of a lot
of people ask like what was it about
paypal why was it so special there were
so many yeah why was that
now meaning
like the constellation of
then largely unknown superstars or just
what paypal became itself as a company
the former okay yeah so why did the
paypal
diaspora
go off and start all of these amazing
companies
yelp
yammer
palantir spacex tesla youtube and i
apologize to any
of my paypal friends if i'm leaving
someone's company it's really just it's
just the list is just crazy yeah and
people always ask the question why was
that the case and i'm not sure there's
one answer but part of it could be the
idea that there was a lot of
latent talent in these individuals that
had been identified by the people who
were hiring them
a lot of potential energy that people
didn't see yeah
let's talk about that for a second what
did you observe if anything about the
hiring process
right you came in at 30 something mm-hmm
and
34 and some of the names that people
would recognize
were not yet fixtures right at that
point
what else did you observe about kind of
team assembly whether
it's at paypal or at clarium or
elsewhere
so two things come to mind right away
one
is
hiring
for
general ability
and
i'm not exactly sure how to say that but
as opposed to saying does this person
have the very specific skills to do this
very specific job
it would be more focused on
is this person
just exceptional in lots of different
ways because if they are they're going
to be exceptional
at whatever job they have to do and a
lot of my experience in a working
environment is at startups yeah where
even clarion capital was a startup it
was a hedge fund with a startup and so
you often have to wear different hats
you often have to switch context a lot
and you kind of just have to be a good
all-around utility player for some
number of years until the organization
scales to the point where you start
hiring more specialized roles so that
was one thing i think hiring for like
general capability as opposed to
specific skill set
i think another thing certainly at
paypal
was and and at palantir to a large
degree
people who didn't have specific
experience in the industry that the
business was in which sounds very kind
of counterproduct not counterproductive
but um counter-intuitive
counter-intuitive thanks
so at paypal
paypal merged with x.com and x.com had a
lot of former financial industry people
and over time gradually
the executives from the paypal team who
had no prior experience in the financial
services industry wound up ascending in
the corporate you know culture and
hierarchy and i think possibly because
they weren't weighed down by
legacy ideas of how things should be
done it it's done this way why because
it's always been done this way right
whereas someone like reed hoffman would
say
well that doesn't make any sense we
should do it this way because this is
the right way
and
and that served paypal really well
for people who are interested i love
reid i've spent a bit of time with him
and he's been on the podcast and
if i remember correctly
at some point peter would refer to him
as firefighter in chief yeah and i mean
reid is so
composed he's just
every time i see him he's got this big
smile he's very calm but just the amount
like the volume of problems that needed
to be solved oh yeah no he is a force of
nature so incredible
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
linkedin marketing solutions time and
place are everything with so many things
and especially this is true in marketing
but in today's age of a million messages
per minute i've seen my phone have you
and seemingly not enough hours in the
day how do you really catch your target
audience's attention fortunately there's
a simple way linkedin can help you speak
to the right people at the right time
with linkedin becoming number one in b2b
display advertising in the us you've got
a great advantage right in front of you
you can stand out against your
competitors while nurturing customer
relationships and growing your brand
linkedin delivers you both quantity and
quality it's targeting tools allow you
to reach your precise audience down to
their job title company name location
and more which means your ads can be
seen by those who matter scale your
marketing and grow your business with
linkedin advertising companies of all
sizes and sectors are using it and now
yours can too it's easy to try linkedin
is now offering a 100 credit on your
next campaign go to linkedin.com
tfs to claim your credit that's like tim
ferriss show so check it out
linkedin.com
tfs
you've mentioned a name a couple of
times now that i'd love to shift to
for people who know it and for those who
don't because i'm sure a lot won't
palantir so i think here is a very
interesting company how did you end up
at palantir
and what does palantir do
so i was at
clarium capital peter's hedge fund
and
at the time he and four other people
co-founded a company called palantir and
that's how i found out about it so peter
invested in it and while i was at
clarium we were also
me and others were helping peter build a
family office and so we were starting to
manage some of his
investments managed just means he had
breakfast with someone agreed to invest
in their company and then would send an
email to us and say hey make it happen
and so we would do those things so
that's how i first met
the ceo of palantir that's how i first
found out about the company i was super
excited about it
right from the beginning and
what the company does is
uses and you know palantir as a company
is very
secretive secretive yeah and and and and
has a low profile so i want to be really
respectful sure yeah
we won't do the unauthorized uh you know
investigative journalism piece but just
people have an idea yeah so at a high
level at the highest level
they help people who have really big
biggest of the big
disparate data sources disparate meaning
they've got data and silos all over the
place
they help them bring that data together
into one cohesive place
so that they can extract insights out of
that data and the thing that we would
talk about is it's not necessarily the
answers it's what questions can you ask
of the data that really starts to define
the value of that data and so palantir
would pride itself on saying
we allow you to ask more and more
interesting questions from your data i
appreciate that answer and i'm going to
stand in for the audience who might want
just a little bit oh sure all right guys
again we're not going to spend a ton of
time on this but just enough
vast
technological capabilities right you
have fantastic technologists and
fantastic technology and platform that's
been built is it fair to say that most
of the customers are governments in some
capacity or another i think were so
certainly started out that way but i
know that they've made a lot of progress
in diversifying their business lines
into commercial spaces got it i couldn't
tell you the percentage difference yeah
so i think two percentages there'd be
like us versus foreign would be one
question and then government versus
commercial yeah and i don't feel versed
enough on
on the data today but certainly at the
beginning
the first customers were the us
government who was really struggling
remember this was not that long after 9
11.
and
one of the things that we learned from
the 911 experience was that yes we had
all of this data but we couldn't do
anything with it yeah it's because
information it's just data it was just
raw data and so that was
one of the reasons palantir was was
formed was to help with that problem
i'm just deeply and again we're not
going to fixate on this but deeply
fascinated by businesses
or people for that matter who
opt for low profile i'm just endlessly
interesting to me right like if you have
whether it's like a daniel day lewis who
just like disappears for five years at a
time then comes out this amazing movie
and then disappears for another three or
four years
or a business whether it's a palantir or
i'm not going to mention them
because it would annoy the people
involved but
some of these hedge fund shops right
they're like little well i shouldn't say
little but they're a certain quant shops
especially that really do not want any
publicity whatsoever and it's because
that is so
contrary
to i think the
trends that exist and the social
pressure
that exists
in this modern age right with social
with
broadcasting
i find it deeply interesting especially
when very smart people are involved
because you kind of assume there are
rational
arguments for why they do it so let's
maybe segue from here
i think it makes sense
to
the
title of the book and we can use that as
a tool for
making a sort of scene shift here so
silicon valley porn star so far silicon
valley has come up porn star has not
come up
so
unless i'm missing something in the uh
the resume on linkedin i don't think
that you had this like short stint in
between undergrad and grad school i did
not okay so fact check accurate
why porn star and you can answer this in
any way that you like but just to give
us an idea of why this
wording yeah
sure
well it goes well together
no
it certainly gets people's attention
yeah the name porn star
came from my life coach
and
we haven't really talked much about the
book yet but i went on this journey
and part of that journey was a
realization that i
was addicted to online porn
and after several years of trying to
stop the habit and not being able to i
finally
realized that i should
tell my life coach this because maybe
she could help me
and
i told her and
we started working on this as part of my
work and she has this technique or tool
where we would
we would say that
a person has a lot of identities in
their
universe
and
if something is
happening in your life that
you want to take a closer look at you
you might assign that behavior to a
specific identity and what it does is
kind of takes it off of you and so then
you can look at it with a little less
shame and maybe a little less judgment
and say hey i'm not a bad person this
identity of mine is doing this thing
that i don't like let's figure out why
and she called that identity porn star
and the first time she said it we both
laughed and it was funny and then then
the name stuck and then
in subsequent coaching sessions we'd get
on the phone and she'd say so how's porn
star doing this week and just like the
levity around it and
her curiosity around it
actually encouraged me to start sharing
things that were otherwise would have
been this very embarrassing to share
and that was really what started a lot
of my healing
let's roll back the clock
and
look at where porn star enters stage
left in a sense
so when did you first recognize
that you had
addiction or an any issues related to
pornography
you know it probably wasn't until
2013 or 14 when
when i felt like this might be a problem
i started looking at porn in
1997 i think whenever i got my first
laptop in college sure and i had an
internet connection and it was super
slow
and it was the pictures took a long time
to load
that's when i started looking at porn
right online and then i just continued i
just thought it was normal yeah every
guy does this right the volume of
content is infinite effectively if
you're immersed in it you just feel like
oh everyone's doing this is and so
the problem for me turned out to be
[Music]
that
it didn't just stop with the porn
and
it was a little bit of kind of a i say
in the book it was a gateway drug for me
so at some point
still images weren't good enough then it
was then video download speeds increased
and then there's video oh that's good
but then at some point
even that wasn't enough for me and then
i started looking for hookups and this
is when i was in a committed
relationship with my girlfriend who's
now my wife
and
that is really when the snowball started
to pick up steam so it was one thing
to look at porn i felt and maybe not
tell my girlfriend about it i mean how
many guys do that right right it seems
like a pretty low percentage
i don't know about that well no no i
mean what i mean is it's a low
percentage you're like hi honey how was
your day and you're eating burritos with
your significant other and they're like
let me tell you the porn i looked down
over my lunch okay that's low percentage
that's the low percentage yeah so
of our generation suffered through very
slow
like practically dial-up speeds to
download like a three-second clip and
you don't know what it's gonna be i
think that's like near 100 yeah it's
pretty high yeah and so
it was one thing to keep that a secret
and lie about that
but once i started hooking up with
people in the real world yeah that kind
of took it to a whole new level and then
i got into
what i would refer to as a shame cycle
yeah and i didn't know it then and it
took me
a long time to figure that out and get
out of it but that's when that started
now
the
i think you
describe this in the book
but did the
hookups
begin with
your lease on your apartment expiring
and
prompting you to go on craigslist yeah
that's that's exactly right so my
apartment lease was going to expire soon
i went on to craigslist to look for a
new apartment that's what everyone did
back then and in the bay area and i
noticed this new
i don't know how new it was but i had
never noticed it before there's a link
in the personal section called casual
encounters maybe it even had a little
new sign next to it or something i don't
know
and i was like oh that's interesting
and i clicked on it
and it was just pages and pages of
people looking for hookups
wild yeah now
in retrospect and maybe you knew this at
the time but
what were the factors contributing to
this
behavior if you want to yeah absolutely
explore that in any way that makes sense
yeah
i didn't understand it at the time it
took me a very long time to to
understand
what was going on under the surface
and you know this goes to kind of one of
the major themes of the book which is
this idea that
unhealed traumas from our childhood
can really affect our behaviors as we
grow into adults so
i believe we are all kind of programmed
in our childhood and then we go out into
the wild and we experience new
situations and we
compare the situation to our programming
to figure out what we're supposed to do
this is a very adaptive human psyche
development i don't think any of that's
controversial and
i had some traumas in my childhood that
i didn't even really understand at the
time were as traumatic to me as they
were the first was when my parents got
divorced when i was young
i was four five or six years old my
father moved away
and
that
i think it affected me you know i didn't
understand how it affected me until i
was in my thirties so it took a really
long time but i think whenever
again i don't think this is super
controversial to say when a primary
caregiver
leaves
it is
very difficult on a child the second
thing that happened for me
was that my mother once i got into about
middle school age and it started a
little bit before that but the sixth
grade was my first awareness of it
really
she started battling with depression
and so she was
in bed a lot
medicated the medical community was
really still trying to figure out what
to do with
depression and anxiety
i feel like they still are
but there was all these medications
prozac
other things
and
so
when she was home
she was
she was kind of distant you know she was
like either in bed or if she was awake
and walking around
she was a little bit distant maybe not
fully there because of this medication
stuff and you know there were good times
but then
there were not so good times and
i think that lasted pretty much through
most of all of middle school and most of
high school and you know those are
formative years for kids we're trying to
figure ourselves out
and
i think that affected me too
and i don't i want to be really clear
and i say this in at the towards the end
of my book i don't blame my parents for
the things that i did as an adult it's
not their fault
i'm just showing the linkage between
an unhealed childhood trauma
that then
maybe impacts your behavior as you get
older
if you don't mind and you can feel free
to climb like when it was
when your behaviors
later right so we're flashing
forward
got to the point where you were like wow
this is a problem and i don't know if
you did that on your own or if it was
someone pointing something out to you
but
what did your
life
slash behavior look like
the moment where it really felt like i
was kind of spinning out of control just
rewinding a little bit i'd been at
paypal for
about three years
made some money
not that much
even by by today's standards certainly
but
more than i thought i would see in you
know my 20s yeah um so i was still
pretty young
and
then i went to clarion capital peter
thiel's hedge fund hedge fund did really
well
and i made big bonuses
and i started investing that money in
startups so again there's like more
money flowing in peter's worth is
climbing
and he's becoming more famous and and i
was part of that
group working for him and so it felt
like we were you know close to this guy
who's becoming kind of a celebrity yeah
in some ways and then you know you mix
in the money and i feel like my ego just
started to really grow and to swell and
then i went to palantir and then
palantir became kind of peter's next big
thing a big silicon valley story i'm the
cfo
anne-marie and i invested a bunch of my
bonus money from clarium into palantir
early on yeah and so we were making a
lot of money on paper
and my ego just was was swelling and i
just
i thought i could do anything i thought
i
deserved anything i wanted and
that was the first kind of peak of bad
behavior where i was just spinning like
a top i just
had lost all direction
now if if you don't want me getting into
specifics
were you
masturbating twice a day to pornography
was it a couple times a week because it
is common right and you pointed out when
we spoke before
you came here for this conversation that
a number of years ago i had this blog
post
about the i think it was no boost no
masturbating 30-day challenge but you
know i've thought enough about this
realizing that it can become a crutch or
a salve or a compulsion
that it's it's interesting to me yes but
i feel like i was way off the deep end
relative to that yeah so let's see yes
so it it went from
you know i've already said it went from
porn to craigslist yep and then
craigslist at some point turned into
online escort websites yep
and then
you know i had that kind of going on in
the background
in addition to porn yep and then i wound
up meeting someone at an event
and starting an affair yeah and that
lasted for months and so all of this
stuff is happening i don't even know how
i had time for all of that like you know
i was wondering yeah it's a lot of time
yeah looking back i don't know
how i was doing that
i guess the way i was doing it was i
completely disappeared on emery i was
just gone i was that's your wife she's
now my wife yes and actually we were
married at the time
that these things were happening by then
and
i was just
gone like in a different world at the
time
what was the story you told yourself
about
those behaviors
in other words was the self narrative
wow i'm spinning like a top this is out
of control i don't know what to do at
that point or
was the story different the story was
different the story had evolved
out of
in our relationship
i wanted to have sex more frequently
than anne marie did
and
at some point
it turned into like resentment
that we're not having as much sex in our
relationship as i want
and i'm a successful man and successful
men go out and they get what they want
and so i am entitled
to this thing that i want and i'm going
to go out and get it because i deserve
to
and that was the narrative i was telling
myself in my head
when did that change
it changed about
six months after our daughter was born
and
i had disappeared on her and then our
daughter was born which of course very
you know is a big event in in any
family
and
we were just
far apart at that point and i could feel
that
at the time i blamed it a lot on how
much i was working
but the distance the feeling yeah the
distance and the feeling i i i wasn't
even
yes i was doing these bad things but
they couldn't be contributing to the
distance because she doesn't know about
them i mean it doesn't make any sense
sounds ridiculous when i say it but
that's the narrative that was playing in
my head and so about six months after
our daughter was born maybe seven months
we were so far apart i felt like
i either need to quit my job or i'm
going to get divorced it was that clear
and
i decided
i'm going to quit my job and i don't
want to get divorced i'm going to quit
my job i'm gonna try to
you know turn this around
and
i started working with a
marriage therapist
she started talking to
a marriage therapist then you know there
was a there are a bunch of different
therapists in the mix and then i wound
up finding this life coach
but there's actually there's there's
another trigger there
so i quit my job
and i think i i stopped in january of
2010
then i was home
and it took me a while to kind of detox
and decompress from palantir which had
been a very intense work environment
but after
four or five months we just weren't
getting closer
and
i
started wondering like what's going on
here and i and i asked anne marie like
hey i stopped working so i could be home
so that we could try to reconnect
and she was like you can't just expect
me to go back to the way things were and
i didn't really have a good thing and it
turned out that she was having an affair
and i kind of discovered that
and
that was a big aha moment as well kind
of a big wake-up call
and she had been in her affair for quite
some time
and that was this huge uh kind of
explosion that happened and then she
moved out
and we separated and
shared time with our daughter split you
know we had her two or three days at a
time
and we both started working with this
life coach with the same woman same
woman yeah which i know is unique and a
little bit unusual but it worked for us
may not work for everyone but it worked
for us now you met her first this life
coach i did did you
did you persuade anne-marie to then use
the same life coach no i called her so i
had been talking with a therapist for i
don't remember how many months four to
six months before i
had my first session with this life
coach just so we have a name this is
melissa her name's melissa yeah
and
i went to my first session with her
and
i felt like i got more out of one hour
with her than i had gotten out of months
of therapy months of like what i would
call traditional therapy right and i'm
not trying to say that to say anything
bad about the therapist i was talking to
i'm sure they're great and they did help
me to some degree but i i got more out
of that one hour
than i had in months and so i was so
excited that i went when i got to the
parking lot i called in marie
and we still had enough communication
lines open for this we were coordinating
schedules for our daughter and things
like that
and i said
i just have to tell you about this
session i just had with this life coach
i didn't know what a life coach was
and i told her
and she said wow you got all of that out
of one hour it's like yeah she said well
maybe i should see this woman too i was
like sure why not and so then she
started and then we just
continued now how initially
and i know some of the details of this
did you meet
melissa
how did that come to pass yeah so
i had divine intervention in the form of
an ea yes absolutely so i had an ea when
i was at volunteer executive
yes
executive assistant amazing woman her
name's julie
a tremendous business partner for me
when i was at palantir
and
she could see that things weren't right
so in this period
you know she could see the things were
not right you know because she was kind
of intimately involved in things that
were going on with me at work and in the
sense that she just with her daily
constant interactions with you could
just feel that something was off
yes exactly she was like are you okay
you know and keep in mind i'm cfo of
this fast-growing silicon valley company
i'm also have all this philandering
activity going on on the side plus i
have a newborn at home
i had a lot going on she didn't know all
of that but she could just tell that i
was like falling apart or fraying at the
seams it just i was not healthy
and
she was like are you okay i was like i
don't think i'm okay
like i don't i don't think i'm okay why
do you ask you know and then
she
said you know there's this woman that i
know who kind of helps people in times
of crisis or
transition and maybe you should talk to
her
and that's kind of how that started
wow
what was the ea's name again her name's
julie so julie gets chocolates
chocolates
she's awesome yeah
all right so there's this explosion
there are discoveries
now i should ask when you learned about
her affair did you at that point share
what you had been up to or were up to or
did
that did that not happen until later
i did not share what i was doing
and
that made some of the things that
happened much later
all the more painful
but no i didn't i played the victim
i said oh my gosh my wife's having an
affair i told my sister i told my
parents told my friends
woe is me can you believe it i just i
just had no idea i would never expected
her to do something like that i mean i
just played into that whole thing
and that was one of the things melissa
called me out on in that first session
oh and the very first very first session
she said you feel like you know because
of telling her the story i share this in
the book i'm telling her the story
and the whole time i'm telling her the
story i'm just expecting her to be like
oh you poor thing
oh you know it wow that's you know how
does that make you feel that sort of
thing so i'm like telling her bits of
the story waiting for this feedback that
the rest of the world had given me the
sympathy and i'm not getting any of it
and i'm like
okay what's going on here
and she's like
and when i finally stopped talking she's
like
you feel like a victim it seems like you
have this victim thing going i'm like
yes i'm a victim you know
you're very good you're you're catching
on you're catching on you're following
me
and uh
but little did i know that you know she
was going to take that in the exact
opposite direction i thought it was
going to go it's like yeah no you've
created this for yourself and i was like
how does she know or you know my i think
maybe my first reaction is
what are you talking about you know
she's like
you've created the condition in your
life for this to happen
and then later in session like before
you come back next week i want you to
write down all of your secrets
i was like how does she know i have
secrets
and it scared the [ __ ] out of me yeah
and she was kind of on to me
right from the beginning from day one
from day one
so how did things then
unfold because you've you've come back
together
with your wife but we're skipping some
in between chapters right you are both
meeting with melissa
what are some of the
key developments
or moments in say the just making up a
number here six months
after you both start working with
melissa well anne marie was pretty clear
that she did not want to end her
relationship that she was in that was of
course very difficult to hear
and then i wound up starting to date
and i had a couple of dating
relationships much you know you were
when you say separated were you
geographically separate were you also
divorced at that point we were not
divorced got it and we
didn't know if we were getting divorced
or not and at first there was this i
don't know if it's a cultural thing but
it's like when something like this
happens in a lot of relationships the
tendency is like that's it we're getting
divorced right
i don't remember
where the advice came from it could have
been from melissa certainly melissa's
advice was don't make any big decisions
for a few months
and i think that was kind of code for
like don't decide to get divorced don't
completely change everything like
there's a lot of work to be done there's
a lot of work that has to be done let's
not go to nuclear immediately yes let's
not go nuclear immediately so we were
separated and marie moved out and had an
apartment it was not that far away a
mile away in san francisco or something
like that and so we're talking to
melissa
let's say in that first six months and
most of the time it's separate i pretty
sure back in those days most of our
sessions were separate although some of
them were together but really were we're
doing our own individual work and one of
the things that was interesting about it
was we were learning a whole new
vocabulary
in the work that melissa was doing
and
we had to stay in touch because we were
coordinating our daughter's schedule
and not to put too much pressure on her
but she really
held us together
during that time
because if we didn't have her
i think we could have easily drifted in
in different directions
so
because of her it kind of kept our lines
of communication open
and we would share sometimes you know
something we might have
learned in one of our sessions here's a
question just on a
sort of on the technical level and i'm
asking because my
girlfriend and i have also at times used
the same let's say therapist yeah and
the therapist to his credit
set certain rules up front and what
could be shared or what would be shared
or would not be shared sort of across
the solo sessions did you guys have any
type of agreement for instance like
that anything was on the table so
anything that came up in your session
could be shared with anne-marie and vice
versa or that nothing would be shared
unless there was sort of explicit
permission granted the latter nothing
would be shared unless there was
explicit permission that's changed now
yeah but back then
you know this whole thing had blown
apart
and
we were not there for sure yeah no i
think it makes a hell of a lot of sense
i was just curious yeah and and melissa
might say is it okay if i share this
thing right
yeah but we we tried she did encourage
us to share with each other can you give
any examples of the shared vocabulary i
want to see if there's maybe a concept
or
language that you could give as as an
example well one of those would be
this idea that
you know like she told me you're not a
victim
you've created this situation in your
life and i'm gonna help you figure out
why
part of what's embedded in that is this
idea
that
you are kind of responsible for
everything that happens in your life and
so that would be a good example where
in those first six months
yes it was the the revelation was that
ann marie had been having an affair i
never came clean on my other behavior
but i started to at least
take responsibility for my disappearance
is related to work right and having no
boundaries around my work
and she i can't remember details of
what her side of that would have been
and i wouldn't i wouldn't want to speak
for her too much anyway for sure yeah
but that was one for me this idea that
i am responsible
and i need to take i'm not a victim i
need to take responsibility for
everything that's happening and another
vocabulary thing that came up during
that time was this idea to simplify and
subtract which for me took on a whole
lot of meaning
when i started my first vc fund i named
it subtraction capital
i was just doing way too many things and
i needed to subtract and simplify
and i think anne-marie had certain
things in her work where she also had to
subtract and simplify what type of work
was she doing when i said work just then
i'm in her work with personal work
right yeah
since this is
i literally have a little sign that i
got when i was in truckee at some point
with this guy named chrissaka a great
guy a good friend and
we went to diner and there was it was
full of all these tchotchkes and there
was this hand-painted sign that said
simplify and i hack i like haggled and
negotiated to buy this from this diner
and put it in my house smart which i
have now smart i think sometimes i'm
better at looking at it than i am at
implementing it but i'm curious for you
what were some of
the meaningful subtractions that were
made and how did you choose what to
subtract i would say it's kind of like
peeling an onion or something it's just
layers and layers and layers like once
you get on this subtraction mentality
and mindset or simplification mindset
you think you're simplifying and you go
through and you and you do much stuff
and then some months later you realize
oh my gosh now i'm going to start
simplifying a totally different level
i'll make this more tangible so at first
it was
so i had left palantir
and
i couldn't
detox immediately or like i couldn't
just cold turkey stop working so i
started trying to get all these
consulting jobs right right you couldn't
go from sixth gear to first gear yeah
yeah and i just so
and i was scared that if i didn't keep
working i wouldn't be able to get
another job when i was ready to go back
to work all these fears
and
so
i had to
start doing less stuff and so as those
consulting jobs ended i didn't get new
ones i started unsubscribing to all of
the email newsletters that i was
subscribed to i didn't really never
watched a ton of tv but i pretty much
stopped watching tv entirely
and
i got a lot more selective i used to
do lots of lunches and breakfasts and
dinners i don't know if it was just me
or if it was silicon valley culture i'm
not sure it's a lot of the latter i
think okay for sure yeah and i was
really wrapped up in that and
and so i had to stop doing that stuff
too
that was another big thing that i kind
of subtracted now again the technique or
go-to
language for that you're just like i'm
sorry
yeah consider me dead for the next two
months or was it uh i sorry i have a
conflict
can't can't make this work
nothing blanket it was always just like
a one-off thing like sorry i can't make
it
or you know frankly i think i was the
one doing a lot of them fighting back
there interesting okay right you were
doing a lot because there was like a
badge of honor it was like all these
lunches and dinners and breakfast i'm so
busy look how important i am oh i'm so
amazing
and
and so i just kind of had to stop
just stop period and be more still
and that's hard to do
how did melissa
sell this to you
right
yeah
she said
you're efforting your way through life
and i was just
livid
i was i was like what are you talking
about you know i have gotten where i am
because i work so hard i was never the
smartest kid in my classes i was not the
smartest person at paypal i was
definitely not the smartest person at
clarium
i got
where i was because i hustled my butt
off i just worked really hard
and so for her to say you're efforting
your way through life was like your
whole strategy
is wrong you know hitting me in the core
and i remember one time
she was telling me this and i was like
well i can't just sit on the couch and
meditate monks don't have mortgages
and then she cracked up i should have
gotten a t-shirt on it monks don't have
mortgages but that was how i felt it was
like i don't know what the spiritual
stuff is you're talking about i can't
meditate i don't have time to meditate
i've got bills to pay
and so she said you're efforting your
way through life i promise you
there is a way to create
just as much abundance in your life if
not more with much less effort
and once i got through the fireworks of
disagreement
i still didn't believe her i was like uh
sure whatever yeah but also i really
wanted to save my marriage yeah and i
didn't want to lose my daughter
or just be
in half of her life or whatever the
arrangement would have been
and so i was willing to
try it
and say
okay let me try it
and i did and i started subtracting
is there a
particular process that she uses to
aid you with that subtraction is there
are there any filters you apply
or is it are you just turned loose with
the instruction too
what i recall from then is a little
fuzzy because it was a long time ago but
one of the things i recall was
this idea
that
she taught me
that
our default state she wouldn't use that
language but
in my words our default state is
peacefulness our default state is
happiness
you know you would say that kids are
really good at reading people's energy
they're really good at assessing like if
someone's safe or not animals have this
sense why do they all have this sense
but adults don't
like what did we do we we put layers and
layers of stuff around that core
part of ourselves that intuition
and
that
in order to get back to that place that
like default state of peacefulness or
happiness or being in tune with others
we had to start peeling away those
layers around the outside we had to
start subtracting those layers
and so that that was part of the
conversation and so
it was
well just look around your life for
things that aren't serving you anymore
could be a relationship it could be a
job it could be a habit it could be
whatever
if it's not serving you and it's not
making you happy get rid of it so
happiness isn't something you find it's
what's left when you get rid of all the
things that make you unhappy right
just sitting with that for a second yeah
i like that it's just
removing all of the detritus and rust
and
nonsense that is gathered around
yeah what is the sort of default core
yeah
let's introduce an acronym
essay not south africa
sexaholics anonymous in this case
where did that enter the picture and did
it enter the picture before or after you
came clean
with your wife
about sort of your side of things
her fair
revelation comes in early 2010
we're separated for a while i never
reveal what's going on with me
we get back together after about a year
and a half and
i'm on good behavior for a while but
then i start in with the bad behavior
again
and in 2014 something happens where i
kind of sort of get caught but i'm able
to say
this never happened before it'll never
happen again
and then in early 2015
i get caught again
and this time
she doesn't believe me melissa doesn't
believe me at that point i have come
clean with melissa about porn for it had
been about a year that i was saying like
i want to work on this porn habit i
don't think it's helping me i think i
need to get rid of it i think i need to
subtract it
and
so i get caught in early 2015 and it's
pretty devastating
because
after everything anne marina had been
through
it was like
she just started feeling like i don't
even know this person
who is this person is there's something
he's not
telling
and melissa understood it too and
i'd kind of spiraled again into a place
where i felt like i kind of lost control
of my life and
she
said
on the phone to me one day
she being she be melissa
you know
we don't believe you
and
if you don't share your secrets you'll
stay sick and if you want to move
forward you're going to have to share
your secrets
and that's when i finally came clean
that's when i kind of the floodgates
opened
and i said okay it's not the first time
this has happened said how many times
has this happened i said
i can't even count i don't know
how long has this been going on
since i can remember i've been going on
for a very long time by then
and i was started crying and said i have
a
serious problem and i don't know how to
stop and i don't know what to do
and she was the one who suggested i
check out a 12-step program
and that's how you know a few nights
later or maybe even that night i
remember
i started researching
12-step programs for sex addiction
and
found myself on the sexaholics anonymous
website reading the material
and just
shocked at how accurately it described
my life
and place us in time then that was
roughly when that was february of 2015
what is your
participation
looked like or attendance i'm not sure
the right term to use sure since then
since then so i attended
at the beginning i attended meetings
several meetings a day
for weeks
trying to find
a meeting and a place and a group of
people that really resonated most with
me
and frankly it was a lifeline for me
because when i revealed this stuff
you know i had to move out yeah again
it's very devastating
and i was very lost
and
very scared
and sa became kind of a lifeline because
it was a group of people who were
suffering through the same thing that i
was suffering through
and so i was there several times a day
at the very beginning that settled into
you know a few meetings a week and i
probably did that for a year
or a year and a half and then
our family moved in 2017 we moved to
singapore for six months for my work
and i stopped going to meetings and then
when i came back i didn't pick it up
again
and i i feel okay with that the biggest
things i took away from the experience
so there's kind of two things that i
want to remark there
one the biggest thing i took away was
if i live a life of humility
and with
love for myself and compassion for
others i will have a good life
i don't need to worry about anything
else like if anyone gets to a really
really bad dark place
if you focus on those three things
you can climb out of that you get more
time you can repeat those if i live a
life of humility
of love for myself
and compassion for others
you can get through just about anything
i think
and so this concept of surrendering i
mean that's the humility piece right was
just so helpful and so important
you said there were two pieces yes there
were two pieces
and at this very moment i can't remember
the second piece i'm so sorry no that's
okay
it's okay we can come back to it yeah so
we let's think about this so i was
asking you about your participation and
attendance since 2015. we flash forward
singapore due to work came back you
didn't pick it back up but i feel okay
with that i feel okay with that and now
i remember the second thing that was my
intention yeah thanks for the reminder
so i feel like
this addiction
topic is a it's a huge topic right we
could talk for an hour just about that
oh yeah many hours and
i feel like
having gone through that experience and
and so i often ask myself i feel like
the cultural narrative a lot of times
with addiction is you know once an
addict always an addict and it becomes
this label
that
you label yourself for the rest of your
life
i'm not sure how i feel about that
the way i've thought about this is
in my experience what led me into that
addictive cycle was shame
and
i feel like if i had to label it with a
different word i would call it a shame
cycle so there's some
kind of
core
shame that happens
and then we go do some kind of behavior
to distract ourselves from feeling that
shame so we don't have to feel it
we do some kind of behavior that maybe
isn't good we feel ashamed of that
behavior now there's more shame now we
go back we act out again so that we can
distract ourselves you know and avoid
feeling that shame and you get into this
cycle and it just piles on and i think
that this is what we have come to term
an addiction
i do feel like it is possible
with
internal work
to go back and understand
all of the layers of shame and
eventually get back to understanding the
root cause of shame
and really actually break that addictive
shame cycle
and i would i would build on that also
just having spent some time looking at
different modalities for treating
various types of addiction i would say
that there's the shame spiral and
there's also a
sort of pain
shame spiral
right where
as a
doctor named gabriel mate would talk
about asking why not why the addiction
but why the pain so people using
there's certainly sort of a shame on
shame spiral as you described which is
the first time i've heard that described
and i think it absolutely
would resonate with a lot of people
listening who experienced this and then
there's the
sort of pain
escape or
numb the pain
and then the shame subsequent to using a
coping mechanism that is not
good in quotation marks or that is bad
in quotation marks that is not socially
acceptable like heroin use for instance
it could be anything else i mean there
are a million different ways it could be
an eating disorder it could be
you name it
and
i agree with you and and
not a therapist not an md i don't play
one on the internet but i do believe
that you can
with the proper guidance and tools
in many instances maybe not all
but go back identify
the
root kind of kernel causes that you're
describing
and then metabolize or re-contextualize
or somehow
contend with those in such a way that
you remove like the initiator in that
first piece of the chain
so now you're describing these meetings
2016 you're in singapore at that point
are you 2017 17 17. said 2017 at this
point are you guys still apart
no so we so i move out in early 2015
february
and
i go into this
really intensive retreat so i'm living
by myself i shut down most of what i'm
doing for work i just do the like the
bare minimum stuff that i need to do to
keep the
it's a vc firm to kind of keep things
moving forward i have to share what's
happening with my business associates
which is incredibly embarrassing
and so i shut down as much as i can
and i start
reprogramming myself i guess i i start
journaling very intensively so i'm going
to essay meetings you know at least a
few times a week i'm journaling very
intensively i stop lifting weights at
the gym i start going to yoga several
times a week actually i mean sometimes
it was twice a day
i stopped eating meat i stopped drinking
alcohol i just change everything i go to
bed when it gets dark and then i wake up
when it's dark and i just journal
together monks do have mortgages monks
do have mortgages in this case yes and
melissa joked that at some point during
that retreat that i was on she's like
i'm not going to call you porn star
anymore and now you're the monk
and i really was living this kind of
monkish life i was just tuning
everything out only reading like
spiritual books
autobiography of a yogi was one of them
more stuff uh books by emmett fox
i don't know i'm at fox i probably
should
oh yeah i like him a lot any any
starting point
i like the sermon on the mount and
there's also a book called the lost
booklets of emmett fox
the biggest thing i take away from from
emmett fox is
this
just reinforcing this idea that
what is happening in your life situation
or in your external universe as as anne
marie and i would say is only a
reflection of what is happening in your
interior universe or inside yourself
and so
that became very important to me at that
time because i had to change i was
running off the programming or
or i was in a shame cycle however you
want to describe it you know the society
had told me i needed money cars and
women to be happy and successful so i
thought i should go out and get those
things and then i was miserable like all
of these things were crashing down
and
i had to change my life
and he was telling me
in addition to melissa tell me you you
have to change inside yourself first so
melissa was still engaged yes so while
you're i still talk to melissa every
week right and during this
aesthetic sort of reclusive
i don't wanna say reclusivity retreat
retreat phase yeah you were still
engaged with her on a regular basis on a
regular basis in fact every time she had
a cancellation she would text me and i
didn't have anything else to do except
work on myself
and so i would take it so i had several
coaching sessions a week during that
period i'm very interested in the things
that worked i'm also wondering were
there any
dead ends like you try anything that you
tried we were like actually
this is counterproductive because you
changed a lot of things i changed
everything yeah i changed everything i
changed my diet i changed my sleep
habits i changed my workout habits i
changed the people i talked to the work
i did i changed
everything
let me ask a question that comes to mind
how much of that if any was
[Applause]
consciously or subconsciously a desire
and a renewed ability to look at
yourself differently
does that make sense like bill sort of
allowing you to regain maybe
confidence or self-respect so that you
could do the work
necessary right when you change so many
things when you change everything you're
basically unrecognizable right
compared to the person that you were
behaviorally speaking
i felt like it was out of necessity
that i had been living with this set of
beliefs
of what would make me happy i had been
lying i was full of shame i was in
danger of my career was at risk because
i was taking bigger risks with what i
was doing in terms of the philandering
and stuff and i was probably risking my
health i was probably risking my safety
i was definitely risking my marriage
like everything that i cared about
was at risk
and so
i think
i just didn't want to lose it all
and that was 2000 was it early early
2015. early 2015
at what point
some notes here these are these are from
your book two books the seed of the soul
and then
that first one is
gary
zukov and then healing the shame that
binds you yeah so those those came in
later i would say
another book that was really
instrumental when i was in the deepest
part of my
journey was love warrior by glennon
doyle so i mean and i read so many books
during that time but the ones that
really stuck out were autobiography of a
yogi
emmett fox's books
glenn and doyle's book love word
and
love where you want to tell you please
yeah love warrior
glennon if you know if you haven't read
the book she just
shares her story
and
is very vulnerable
and
i was in a very dark place and trying to
figure out like
how did this happen to me how did i get
here and and there's some themes of that
in her book as well
and it just really helped me feel less
alone and like there was some kind of
path that i could take to get out of
this
how did
you
end up coming back together with
anne-marie
so during that time
you know she
at first i thought we were getting
divorced like i just thought there was
no way we're gonna recover from this
and melissa
said
hey anne marie
if you were engaged in this co-creation
with jason for so long
you must have been getting something out
of it
you created this in your life and i'm
gonna help you figure out why it's the
same message right as the message is the
same for everyone
and
she recommended a book to the two of us
called women who love too much by robin
norwood i've heard a lot about this book
i've never i've never read it it's a
great book yeah and in that book she
talks about how women who
are in families with an addicted parent
and anne-marie's father suffered with
alcohol and drug addiction when he was
younger
when she was younger and he was younger
and
they tend to get into relationships
with
other addicts or people who are not
emotionally available in some way and
you know addiction definitely does that
to a person
and so
as odd as it sounds it was a very
comfortable place for anne-marie to be
with a guy who was not fully emotionally
present
because if i had been fully emotionally
present it would have been very
uncomfortable unfamiliar unfamiliar and
uncomfortable and so
we read that book
and it really
changed the way we thought about
everything that was happening
and
she started to understand this as well
but she was also she also got very clear
you know with her boundaries
like
you need to fix this you need to climb
out of this i understand you're on a
journey i understand you have work to do
but if i ever feel like you're not
working and you're not taking this
seriously then we'll get divorced it was
that clear and i was like yes ma'am
you know like i am going to do this and
i really wanted to get well i didn't
want to lose
her and i didn't want to lose my
daughter
when did melissa
reach out to
anne marie or were they also having an
ongoing ongoing oh yeah
when i started
way back in
2010 when i started working with melissa
anne-marie started working with her
around the same time and we both still
talked to her on a weekly basis
so she was during that time
we had a lot of joint sessions during
this time in early
2015 and then by august of 2015
we came back together
so i was only on retreat it seems like a
short amount of time it was for
four and a half months but it was really
intense and it felt like a very long
time
and we both changed a lot during that
time me a lot more than in marie
and we came back together
and
have been together ever since and it's
been beautiful what have been some of
the most important
keys to the
repair process like repairing trust
in both in both directions right but
particularly
after getting back together after the
retreat
are there particular things that come to
mind when i
ask that yeah it took a long time
you know more
for her to trust me again yeah
it took time it just i can't imagine her
also just being not just distrusting at
various points but also really pissed
off yeah that you had
and i'm not casting judgment here but
that you had
kept your secrets while condemning her
absolutely
that was
horrible it was just horrible thing for
me to have done
that's what made it so devastating yeah
were there any particular steps or any
particular
conversations
you know aside from time healing always
right which which may or may not be true
maybe deliberate practice heals a lot of
wounds but what were some of the things
that helped yeah and and to your point
about healing wounds i mean anne marie
has said this
and i thought it was kind of a
lovely way to put it or an interesting
way to put it that
yes time heals those wounds but you
still have scars yeah you know we still
know what happened
and it's all been part of our journey
and we appreciate everything that our
journey has taught us
but those things still happen then they
were still painful
what safeguards do you put in place i'm
just imagining there's ubiquitous
high-speed wi-fi everywhere you have
laptops right and if pornography
on some level is like the gateway drug
that opens pandora's box
what are some of the rules and
parameters
or guide rails that you have for
yourself
nothing technology related so i don't
have special filters on my phone or
anything like that so i went so 2015
this whole thing blew open
i moved back in kind of mid-year let's
say august late summer
i went two full years without looking at
porn at all i didn't even think of it i
think one day i woke up i was like oh my
gosh it's been six months since i looked
at porn like
well actually in the very
dark first period it was it was hard um
but anyway at some point it was like it
just disappeared it was off the radar
and it was i didn't have special filters
on my phone i just never went into it
and then i don't remember what happened
but i got kind of called back to it
but this time i was really open about it
with both melissa and anne-marie said
hey this interesting thing happened i
wanted to look at porn again
and so that
was interesting and in my conversations
with melissa it was like
this thing is here to teach you
something
if you're going to engage with it you
need to get curious
how am i feeling when this is calling me
how am i feeling when it's happening how
do i feel afterwards
and as i started to get more curious
about it that's essentially like turning
the lights on it's not fun when the
lights are on
that's very
yeah i know it takes all the fun out
yeah desexifies the process absolutely
and so so it has been that process so it
you know
it's been a long time since it's come
knocking
i would be lying if i said it has never
that it never came knocking again i
would say probably on average once or
twice a year yeah something happens but
when that happens birthday morning of
the birthday no
um
but when that happens i get curious
about it yeah what's going on in my life
usually there's something that's
happening that i'm maybe i'm in
resistance to maybe there's something
i'm afraid of
but these things kind of operating
somewhat subconsciously that i'm not
really aware of and this becomes the
canary in the coal mine that tells me
something's not right and that becomes
an entry point into my work and so i
don't want to have
filters or rules or anything like that
my
belief as it relates to these kinds of
things is
if it's calling me there's a deeper
reason and if i just avoid it
then i'll never
really understand what that deeper
reason is
not only that but it strikes me that if
you are suppressing it's probably going
to like squeeze out some corner of that
box you're trying to compartment very
easily and it'll manifest in some other
way that's right now
let me just play devil's advocate though
yeah
sexual drive very
fundamental right to human existence
and
i could see if
pushing that to an extreme you could end
up
inflicting a narrative of shame on
yourself even if you
let's say want to masturbate
which i think is a very natural
impulse on a whole lot of levels so this
this is to get too super granular but
are you permitted or do you allow
yourself to masturbate and porn assisted
masturbating is sort of a separate class
because i do think
those experiences are very different
right i mean i think most men would
agree i mean because you like if you
look at porn today versus porn five
years ago versus porn ten years ago i
mean it's like an arms race it is so
extreme and it just gets more and more
extreme it's really just yes and it's
and it's not all
no over the top but a lot of it is so
extreme that it
dehumanizes you it can be dehumanizing
and also at the very least is
desensitized to the point that
even very
exciting sex on any normal level
really can't compete in
the mind with what you can get
instantaneously online i mean it's it's
very very challenging right
how do you think about any of that
i think masturbation is kind of a normal
thing
yeah and probably
yeah i i don't have any specific issues
with that
what i do
think is very bad is porn yep in any
amount
at any time i think that zero is the
right amount i think it is toxic i think
it is hurting our young men
yeah i agree i think it is hurting young
women
i think it's just bad just all around
and
i think masturbation's fine but i i
think anything with porn is not good
yeah don't put it on steroids with the
porn assistance
why do this book because
these are subjects that most people
would love to avoid talking about
publicly that's it that's like a great
reason to do it
i feel like we should be talking about
these things more that that's not why i
did it but i
as i'm
experiencing the process of putting this
book out into the world it is amazing
you know i was sitting next to someone
on a plane this woman on a plane it was
a
plane taking off from la so everyone's
in the entertainment business and she's
like oh is that a manuscript
yeah
it's mine i wrote a book and i'm i'm
reading it what's it about and i'm
thinking well here we go here we go you
know i'm gonna have to start telling
people soon and so i tell her and then
she starts opening up to me about things
that have happened in her life and with
her family and it was like
so much of the stuff is going on it's
below the surface
and i think if we talk about it with
less shame and less judgment it could be
really healthy for all of us yeah that's
not exactly why i wrote it there are a
group of people out there men and women
who are hurting
maybe they're locked in some kind of
shame cycle
maybe they have been chasing after the
things that society told them to chase
after and they got those things and then
realized they were miserable
and then when that happens it's very
disorienting as i said earlier and can
be very scary and they could be in a
very dark place and i hope that for them
this is
a beacon of hope
that says hey
i'm not perfect either
it's okay none of us are perfect
there's a way out that you can change
and if you look inside and go on that
inward journey you can heal and you can
find your way out of this place
i think there's a secondary group which
is young men
i hope that this can be a little bit of
a cautionary tale of what not to do
i just kind of blindly followed this
thing that society was telling i thought
society was telling me money cars and
women i know for other young men it's
different things who grow up in
different
different areas but for me it was money
cars and women and i should have
challenged that assumption i should not
have just blindly followed that because
that didn't make me happy
and then i think the last
group that i feel like this could
potentially help our couples
because anne-marie and i went through
some very very difficult things
but we used those difficult experiences
as
opportunities to grow to you know learn
about ourselves to heal ourselves to
grow as individuals and then to grow as
a couple
and i feel like
if this could inspire a couple out there
to get more honest with each other
and hold some space for each other to
not be perfect and to that you can make
a mistake in a committed relationship
and it doesn't have to mean the end of a
relationship i feel like that would be a
good thing
i think it'd be a tremendously
tremendously powerful thing i mean i
think i'm not that old but i'm 44 or 45
i forget i'm getting old enough that i
forget how old i am that i've been able
to see a whole cohort of my close
friends get married get divorced
get married have trials and tribulations
and all sorts of challenges
and
i feel like the questions that you raise
in your
in this conversation in the book in your
story
the challenges that you talk about are
in many ways in some form or another
ubiquitous
right it's just you don't hear
at least i don't hear many people
talking about them openly but the fact
of the matter is
it's everywhere it's everywhere and i i
say this in the afterword of the book i
say
my story was a story about
getting lost in this porn thing and sex
addiction and things like that and then
finding myself you know starting to heal
and then finding myself
there's some intermediate steps as well
that you mentioned earlier there's like
the pain and then there's the
self-medicating to avoid the pain and
then there's the kind of redemption and
self-discovery that can happen
afterwards
and i feel like that's a universal story
i feel like so many people have that
story
and
that's one of the reasons i wanted to
share it
the porn stars journey
yeah
it's a good title monks have mortgages
monks don't have mortgages that's right
i was just thinking about your retreat
yeah and the the contrast
so the timeline that plays out in the
book
leaves us
i believe april 2015.
yeah
august 2015 august yeah that was close
yeah it started with an a
well so what have the years since looked
like and
specifically i'd love for you to comment
at some point on what has been most
challenging for you
and also i know you don't want to speak
for her but for ann marie what has been
challenging
because i bring this up for a very
specific reason and that is
when we talk about these stories of
redemption sometimes
this could be related to
a particular
this might sound like a strange example
but like a particular surgery a
particular type of cancer treatment a
particular type of psychedelic therapy
for
say complex ptsd
where people hear these stories of
redemption but sometimes mistakenly
believe
that
everything is solved
and it's sometimes helpful to set
expectations that hey you're still gonna
have to like row the rowboat and there
there's probably gonna be more work
involved
it is a lifetime journey right you know
and
there's no end to reach yeah and so i
would say the way i've described it is
in the early part it was like i'm you
know we like to use the metaphor
climbing our spiritual mountain so i'm
climbing my mountain and there's like
giant boulders blocking my path that i
can't get past or
and the only way to get past them is to
crawl through some dark cave where
there's something really scary in there
and i'm scared and so in the early part
of the climb it was like that
once you get past
those kinds of parts it gets a lot more
subtle
there was a whole
phase
after all of this stuff where i feel
like
every
three or four or maybe six months
something else would happen where the
answer for me was like you need to
surrender even more
and could you just just remind me what
that means to you
to surrender maybe you have an example
you could share any example where you're
like
okay universes i get it yeah this is
time for me i feel terrible that i i'm
not i'm not coming up with a example
i'll tell you what right away i think i
can i think i could get us there
laterally yeah think of can you think of
a time where you're doing the opposite
of surrendering
you're just like halfway the [ __ ] out of
it yeah
maybe in my venture capital work okay i
mean we have two funds
i tried so hard with my business partner
to raise our second fund
and
we came in way short of our target
and i was just working so hard and so
putting so much effort into that and
then after it didn't happen after it
didn't manifest
and i know there's a school of thought
out there that's like well that means
you didn't work hard enough and you just
need to work harder next time and so on
and so forth but i kind of took it as a
sign of like
maybe this just isn't the right thing
for me yeah like maybe i need to do
something different and so maybe i need
to let go of that thing
and then i did
and then i decided i was going to write
a book
and now this book thing is taking me in
a completely new direction that's very
fun very exciting very engaging
and i'm so thankful yeah and i think
that came from letting go of that thing
and kind of surrendering and saying i
need to listen to this sign yeah that
makes me think of something that seth
godin the author
does a lot more than just write but this
is
author he's famous for
many many books he's written god knows
how many i don't know 20 30 who knows
but seth is
one of the wisest people i know and he's
crafted a very unique life for himself
along with his amazing
wife and the way he's parented is really
really
unusual i think
impressive
and he at some point told the story of
me of
pushing boulders downhill instead of
uphill and he tells the story of this
woman who'd been trying to sell
some type of i'm going to get the
details wrong but
sell some type of toy concept i don't
know if it was a board game or something
else to all of these various types of
manufacturers to license the idea and it
was just no after no after no after no
and he recommended just pivoting ever so
slightly to something that was already
getting
all sorts of rave support from
i want to say a handful of friends or
family and to take a different approach
and to push basically not to do the hard
thing because it allows you to prove
what you can achieve by working hard
and
she ended up having this massive success
and it was by looking for the path of
least resistance yes and you know that's
been a concept for me over time too this
idea of conservation of energy yeah
and saying
if it's that hard maybe it it's not the
right thing to do and yes move in the
direction of the thing that's coming
easier because the first
version is like kind of a controlling
version it's like i know what the answer
is supposed to be and and i have to
manifest that answer whereas the second
version is more of a surrender approach
and saying
i don't know what the answer is going to
be
i'm going to move in this direction yeah
and that
has that has served me well
what continues to be or over the last
say five years
what are some of the things that are
still
that you still find challenging
i could think of a way to phrase that
differently no no it's a good question i
still have a tendency to
be in my head more than i would like i
would like to
embody my body more than i do
but it does not come easily for me
and i have to work at it
i think partly related to that i
probably have a tendency to
make myself
busy sometimes
as opposed to just having a little bit
more stillness in my life
and so i think to me
all that means is
those are actually good things in my
opinion because those are entry points
for the work i feel like the most
difficult times of this kind of inward
work and and journey have been the times
where i didn't really feel like i had a
good entry point you don't have enough
grist for the mill yeah cause then it's
like well i know i need to
keep climbing my mountain but i'm not
exactly sure what direction to go so
then you just put one foot in front of
the other for a while and then something
pops up that's not good or not serving
you or you don't like and then say oh
okay there's an entry point and so
sometimes those are a gift
is there anything that
has
stuck
in particular
from your retreat period your four and a
half months or whatever it was is there
is there anything because you changed
everything
yeah it changed everything
were there any particular things that
have
stuck in part or
wholly after that you know probably
uh subtract subtract subtract simplify
simplify simplify like i
every day i feel like i just i'm waking
up saying
what do i not need to be doing anymore
what shouldn't i be doing anymore is
there a relationship that's not serving
me anymore
now let's take that last example because
this is one that i know people have
tremendous difficulties
so okay they identify a relationship
that's not serving you anymore let's for
the sake of argument just say it's not
your most significant other right let's
just say it's not that but you you
identify
friend x and you're just like yeah this
is run its chorus what do you do then
i think for me that the signal
is there's a great quote from maya
angelou i'm probably gonna get it wrong
but it's something like this people will
forget what you say they will forget
what you do but they'll never forget how
you make them feel
and
if there is someone in your life
co-worker friend
family member whatever where every time
you interact with that person you kind
of leave the interaction not feeling
good yeah that's your body's
intelligence that's what when i say i
want to embody my body more i want to
listen to those signals for sure because
the more i've done that by the way
the better i feel like i perform in like
a board meeting
or with an entrepreneur
because i'm picking up on much subtler
signals yeah my mind is quieter and i'm
i'm picking that stuff up
so if you notice that
then
i'm not sure i understand why it's hard
no
well tell me what you do yeah then we'll
find out i think you just let it
i think you just let it go
right just
okay so so you're like all right i don't
want to throw
there probably a lot of joes out there
uh we don't want to throw joe into the
box augustus all right augustus you're
like augustus every time i go to
barbecue with this guy invites me out
for coffee i come away and i just feel
slightly drained well the next time you
get invited maybe you're too busy to go
okay and then he invites you the next
week and then maybe you're too busy to
go okay and eventually you hope that
augustus just gets the gets the signal
yeah i think so i mean you could take
the other approach which is hey when we
spend time together i don't really feel
good afterwards or that feels like a
tall order i don't have the guts to do
that
okay got it all right so it's the slow
fade i i think so i think these things
just fade and what i feel like
you know
a lot of people are resistant to this i
you really did
in my opinion you hit the nail on the
head this is the one that people are the
most resistant to they pride themselves
on i've been friends with this person
since kindergarten right like a badge of
honor yeah but
people change
yeah and maybe it does make sense to be
friends with someone from first grade
but maybe it doesn't
maybe by keeping yourself locked in that
orbit you're
not allowing yourself to change yeah
that person's not changing and so when
you let go of these things it doesn't
have to be mean
it can still be beautiful but it also
opens up space for a new relationship to
enter
that is a match for where you are now or
if there's a gap there for a little
while and you change
and then there's a new relationship that
starts based on the new person that you
are
let's shift gears a little bit just to
some
broader questions if that works for you
yeah and then we can always come back to
some more of the specific but
since you know i mentioned before we
started recording i was like yeah
sometimes i ask these questions of a lot
of my guests sometimes they don't really
go anywhere
and i'll take the the fall for that we
can always edit it out but i mentioned
the billboard question and you said oh i
have an answer for that so i haven't
heard it yet so to repeat the question
that a lot of folks have heard so you
could put
a quote
a message word question image whatever
non-commercial
on a billboard again metaphorically to
get a message out to billions of people
assuming they all understand it
what might you put on that billboard
this idea of climbing our spiritual
mountain
has just become so fundamental to our
life
that i would say
something like keep climbing your
mountain or don't stop climbing don't
stop maybe keep climbing your mountain
or just keep climbing that might be that
just keep climbing there are so many
questions over the last you said what
are the last seven years been like and
after those big boulders and caves
there's more subtle stuff but it's still
there there's still work and there's so
many times i'd ask gamer a question
should i do this or should i do that you
know it's maybe it's a business question
could be related to
whatever
usually a business question
and her response would be
just keep
climbing and i'd be so frustrated and
annoyed be like okay
yeah i'm trying to make a choice here
and then and then i would be like no no
just just keep climbing you'll the
answer will reveal itself just keep
climbing
and then i would go away and i would
keep climbing and sure enough
it would resolve or the answer would
resolve it would present itself
what books i mean soon the answer will
likely be your own book but putting your
own book aside
what books have you gifted the most or
recommended the most to other people
mm-hmm
love warrior
the one i talked about earlier by kevin
doyle
the power of now by eckhart tolle
that book changed my life blew my mind
if you're going to read that book take
it slow in my opinion i can't tell you
how many people i've met where they're
talking to me about some issue or
problem in their life and i'm like you
should read the power of now and they're
like oh i read it
and i'm like no you didn't you need to
read it again because if you really
read it you wouldn't be saying what
you're saying right now um there's a
book in 2018 maybe really trying to let
go of of the shame that i carried
because even after i was healing myself
i still had a lot of shame for a long
time i was very embarrassed about the
things that i had done
so the shame was
for my own clarity was the pornography
and the cheating and the cheating and so
on yeah absolutely very
embarrassed
upset with myself
ashamed yeah
and uh there's a book called healing the
shame that binds you right john bradshaw
amazing book and by the way i read these
books more than once like some of these
i've read four or five times because
i'll read them once a year come back to
them
those are three that really stand out as
having been really impactful another one
really just the sexaholics anonymous the
12-step program literature which is all
the same by the way for every 12-step
program so i wound up reading the
the blue book of alcoholics anonymous
and that was amazing i've been meaning
to read that for some time now yeah it
was it was very powerful
let's talk about
investments but not perhaps in the
traditional sense so outside of the
financial investments
can you think of a particularly
any very good investment that you've
made
worthwhile could be time could be energy
not to quote warren buffett but i will
he talks about his best investment being
investing in a dale carnegie speaking
course because it's sort of a multiplier
for all of your other powers
that might be part of his like aw shucks
grandpa stick that he does so who knows
but nonetheless you get the idea for
other people
the answer varies widely but do any any
examples or options come to mind
absolutely all right
it's hard to give these an order because
they're
they're tied for first place i would say
perfect
i've paid a lot of money for life
coaching work yeah you know over 10
years
it has been worth every penny it has
been worth
so much more
that was an investment in myself
that is just has been priceless and so
to anyone out there who wants to talk to
a therapist or a life coach or something
and who uses
if you can afford it but you're kind of
choosing not to afford it because you're
worried about the cost or you don't want
to spend the money on it
i would rethink that because that work
made me a more successful financial
investor
and so all of that has come back to me
you know if you just want to use the
dollars it's come back to me but
as far as what it's done for my
relationships with my wife and my
children that's priceless and so that's
a good segue the second one is
i have invested a lot of time over the
last seven years in my relationship with
my wife and with my kids
in fact
i feel like my kids
i often get asked when i tell people i'm
kind of phasing out of being a venture
capitalist like well what are you going
to do you're going to get bored and like
no i have two kids
and
helping launch two humans into the world
is actually a huge responsibility
like i don't think we all appreciate
sometimes how big of a responsibility
that is
and investing in them and investing in
their relationship my relationships with
them
has been
the best investment
in addition to the coaching work like
those things that's how someone asked me
recently like how do you define success
for yourself it's like those
relationships that's it so if i may
take us from the
sublime to the ridiculous for a second
please i want to ask you about excel
microsoft excel oh sure
this is from i'm i'm reading here
i want to see
if this is any way ties in because i'm
also curious about the sort of early
investments so this is from business
insider piece from god knows when it's a
piece called career advice from peter
thiel's mentee or at least that's what
they called it in the url who knows what
they end up calling the headline
so on my first day of the company nobody
knew what i should do a chemical
engineering major who knew a little
about business it turns out that i did
have one really valuable skill at the
time i knew a lot about microsoft excel
one of my undergraduate professors and
this is where the name comes in yeah
dr david clough clough
c-l-o-u-g-h had insisted that we all
learn a lot of the more powerful and
sometimes obscure features of excel yes
so when i got to paypal yeah i was
i was a finance major you know i had
been a chemical engineering major and
then i was in this kind of quasi-finance
business
graduate degree program
and
like i said earlier the focus was not on
hiring necessarily a specific skill set
just with all capacity hiring on general
capacity so they saw something in me and
said we don't know exactly what he's
going to do but just get him in here
yeah and so i went in and the first day
i was like what should i do and the
controller
the uh accounting controller and the
finance team was like well
something about a general ledger and i
was like what's a general ledger
and she looked at me like you've got to
be kidding me like what what
who are you
and so anyway i was started doing some
stuff in excel tracking metrics
basically because there was this daily
report that would come out of the system
and i would start started keeping track
of it every day and then sending around
graphs to everyone and
i was just good with excel and that kind
of launched my career at paypal so i
have a lot of gratitude for for
professor clough and i owe him a lot so
he was
a professor of what he was in the
chemical engineering department at
university of colorado and
in as i again mentioned earlier in
chemical engineering you have like
thermodynamics stuff you have a lot of
calculus
differential equations like things that
start to
use some of the more obscure features
and functions in excel yeah and he
always insisted that we learn that stuff
so here's a question i've never actually
had a chance to ask anyone and i just
occurred to me i should probably ask i
don't know a lot of cfos or people who
have been cfos
what makes
and we can abstract this i was going to
ask what makes a great cfo but you could
also answer that by giving maybe an
example like thinking of someone in your
mind of
someone who's
a superstar cfo
and
what differentiates one from the next
right exactly because i can think of
cfos and you have these
all these different archetypes right
then in the cfo
category right even cmo i can imagine
certain things but i'm not
a
certainly not a mathematician i'm
certainly not an accountant i don't even
begin to understand or i can't pretend
to understand what a cfo does
day to day
so i don't know what differentiates one
from another right because i'm like well
like all right you got like first in
first out you got some accounting
principles you got to make sure you
behave on some level for like the sec in
certain circumstances i'm like
what differentiates them yeah so it's
not a one-size-fits-all thing yeah right
so different companies need different
things so the cfo of boeing is um
probably a much different skill set than
the ceo of paypal or the cfo oh sorry
cfo yeah the cfo of a of a company
that's building airplanes or something
else right
is
different than the skill set of someone
in financial services to some degree so
i have coached a lot of
financial leaders from managers up to
c-level and the way i
explain this to them because you meet a
lot of vps in all different
roles vp of marketing or vp of finance
and they all think they well they want
to be the c level so i'm the vp of
finance i want to be the cfo i'm the vp
of marketing i want to be the cmo
what separates the vp from the c level
in my opinion
the shorthand i give them is that the c
stands for confidence
and it's not necessarily that the cfo
knows more about the technical
accounting or the technical financial
analysis or the treasury function or
whatever is happening
but
there's something about the energy that
they carry whether that comes from
experience
or it's just innate to them but there's
something about the energy they carry
that when they walk in the room
it inspires confidence
and
i think that's
that's and so but again these things are
different for different companies at
different stages if i had to pick
an amazing cfo
i would pick
my boss when i was at paypal and i'm not
just saying that you know to be
obsequious he was amazing his name is
roloff botha oh he's now the head of
sequoia capital globally so it's not a
fluke
he has been exceptional
his entire life i mean i didn't know
when he was younger before paypal we
actually funny enough we overlapped at
one of those classes at stanford one
time so when we met each other at paypal
was like oh i recognize you you know i
saw you in class
but he was an amazing boss an amazing
mentor
and for what paypal needed at that time
an incredible cfo because
one of the biggest issues paypal had was
fraud in the early days and people
defrauding the system and he had been
trained as an actuary and really
understood like risk management and
cohort analysis and things that none of
us knew anything about
and
he brought that to bear at paypal and it
was a
i mean
priceless contribution he was he was
amazing and he's just a great human very
very bright guy i maybe met him once in
like 2009 like hello goodbye kind of
thing it's some like god knows what
silicon valley event he's busy oh yeah
but uh i've i've heard so many good
things yeah about him what are some of
the other things that you observed in
him or learned
from him he said a great boss what made
him a great boss you know i was so young
it wasn't just
he taught me so much about finance but
he also asked a silly question yeah what
do you learn about finance on the job on
the ground in an environment like that
that you don't learn in school i know
that might seem really stupid but i'm
just wondering well in school when we
learned about financial modeling
it was
more equation based as it almost sounds
silly when i say that but
when i got to paypal roloff had built a
very detailed financial model in excel
that really turns out to be like a very
sophisticated accounting tabulation of
everything that's happening in the
business
which you can then use to forecast
what's going to happen based on if you
tweak this cell based on certain
assumptions right and then you can do
sensitivity analysis and things like
that and so
it went from being this like esoteric
concept to
really tangible and really powerful
the other thing that he did for me that
i still
thank him for to this day
was
he brought me along to so many meetings
that he was attending oh that's his gift
it was such a gift and most of the time
i just sat there but like i probably
made the spreadsheet or printed things
out on the printer or helped him prepare
for the meeting and then he would say
well you can come with me and i would go
in and i would sit and i would listen
and i learned so much about
how he
had those conversations with people
sometimes difficult conversations
you know the subtlety the art of
the softer side of business when he was
interacting with the investment banks he
would invite me to listen in on those
phone calls or attend some of those
meetings
and man i learned so much
i have to imagine just knowing some of
the stories
the early days stories from when i had
uh reid hoffman on the show
that some of those conversations with
investment banks must have been
fascinating absolutely yes yes yes uh
paypal had a lot going on we had a lot
going on yeah oh man what an exciting
journey
you have had uh of course with
the bad with the good and the the down
with the up but
nothing i would not trade it for
anything i know
i went through this really weird thing
into the dark
the porn stuff the sex stuff
but man it taught me so much
so closing question-ish i always caveat
that because i'm prone to saying last
question and a half hour later we're
still going
men and women listening or if i want to
be a little less what is it cisgendered
just people listening who are in
relationships
committed relationships and they think
to themselves
i should have a conversation about this
with my partner oh i hope they do right
now whether
they have secrets
or they wonder if their partner has
secrets or anything
in between
[Music]
what advice would you give them
in terms of how to open those
conversations
or when or if to open those
conversations yeah
this actually fits in with a question
you asked earlier that i didn't really
get to which is like
the healing process and and how do you
trust someone again
and i think there's several different
sides of it one side is
when you're looking at that other person
maybe don't necessarily see them as
that person in that moment but see them
as a soul that's on a journey
through
this life
that is learning lessons
and trying to figure out what those
lessons are and trying to learn them so
gary zukov says this in seed of the soul
that in the old days marriages were
based on like maybe political
affiliation or alliance maybe survival
necessity in the very earliest days and
then it was like alliances and political
stuff and then it was love you know we
were in this phase where like marriage
is all about love but his feeling was
that
in the future
what will define a successful marriage
is
mutual commitment to each other's
spiritual growth
and so when you're in that relationship
if you can
take yourself out of it for a moment
and say we are two souls moving through
this lifetime together and we're both
learning lessons what are these lessons
how can we learn from each other how can
we help each other
then when the person reveals a secret
that might be hurtful to you you might
be able to absorb it
a little bit instead of get immediately
getting angry or immediately taking you
personally
and absorbing it is another way of
saying holding that space right you
might be able to hold that space
for that other person
and that is a gift and that is intimacy
and that is what it means to work
together in a relationship because
you're in a relationship for a reason
the universe has brought you two
together for a reason you're supposed to
be learning things from each other
and so help each other
in that learning don't just say you did
the wrong thing i'm out
because
guess what both of you are gonna go on
to repeat the same things
until you learn the lesson so why not
just stick with each other a little bit
longer
i understand that there are some
relationships that maybe shouldn't
proceed like especially if there's abuse
or something like that that's very
serious but i do think
in our modern society there is a
tendency to pull the rip cord
pretty
early
so i'm gonna
come back to this thread and this is
related but this is a very specific
question i'd love to know your thoughts
on which is
let's just say
since we're sitting here we're talking
about your story let's just say it's a
male who
has
issues with porn maybe it's gone beyond
porn
wants to
open up and be
vulnerable and honest with his partner
would you
recommend they have that conversation
and then
take the
next steps towards say
addressing some of those issues or would
you suggest they potentially
start with a 12-step program take these
steps to begin addressing the issues and
then have the conversation
my first reaction is
and it's it's hard i i try to be careful
to generalize because i know what worked
for us
but doesn't mean it would work for
everyone you know
but the way it unfolded for us was that
we had this third party intermediary
right neutral third party intermediary
who told us at the very beginning i
think we did have a joint session fairly
early in our coaching and she said
i'm never gonna pick sides
i don't really care if you guys get
divorced or stay together i just want to
help you both become well
and healthy and whole individuals
because if you're healthy and whole and
well
if you decide to get divorced it'll be
fine you won't need tons of lawyers
it'll just get divorced and if you
decide to stay together it would be
beautiful so it'll be
beautiful either way
i think it's good to have
an intermediary to help you through
something like that because
it helps i think it can help
yeah c's can get a little rough i
imagine
any other
thoughts for
people who want to open a conversation
whether it's asking a
partner all right turning to them and
asking whether they
say it's related to pornography
and not to be too much of a spoiler but
you know be prepared for an affirmative
answer i'd say in most right
yeah just just go into that expecting a
yes
but
any other recommendations for people who
might want to have
a conversation around these topics well
i mean aside from
potentially trying to find someone who
can be a trusted third-party
intermediary that can kind of help
you
hold space for each other
i mean my other recommendation is
that my healing again it's hard to
generalize my healing started when i
finally started to reveal my secrets
and
i feel like
the sooner the better yeah the sooner
the better
try to find someone who can help you
through it try to hold space for each
other
and try to grow
that way you know in love
well jason you can be found at
jasonportnoyportnoy.com
that's for the general departure point
for all good things the new book silicon
valley porn star which is easy to
remember
so you definitely
you have that going for you with the
book is it memorable
title is there anything else that you
would like to
add any closing comments public
complaints you'd like to make
about this podcast and how it's gone or
requests of the audience anything you'd
like to point attention to anything at
all that you'd like to add before we
draw this to a close
you know i think i would like to
i'd like to thank anne marie
for being such an amazing
life partner
and for
allowing me to go through what i went
through
and for holding that space and then for
encouraging me
with this book writing process and
supporting me through that she's just
been
amazing and incredible
so thank you
perfect way to end
jason thank you so much for sharing your
story and taking the time with me also
this has been
an enjoyable conversation and
enlightening conversation i've taken a
lot of notes myself i've highlighted a
number of different books including your
own
and
i think that by writing this book by
having these conversations you will do a
lot of good because
as we covered earlier
these types of challenges are
ubiquitous the conversations may seem
few and far between but the
challenges the issues you know the caves
and the boulders that we're talking
about
are ubiquitous
and have existed in some form or another
for a very long time a lot of these not
all of them but
i do think it's a service to
put them on the table as subjects that
can be discussed well i appreciate you
saying that and i really appreciate you
using
your platform as a venue to do that
my pleasure entirely
and
for folks who are listening we will
include links to everything we've
discussed of course including silicon
valley porn star and all of the various
resources
names etc in the show notes per usual at
tim.blog
podcast and until next time be a little
bit kinder than is necessary to others
and to yourself
and thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim dot blog friday type that into your
browser tim.log
slash friday drop in your email and
you'll get the very next one thanks for
listening
this episode is brought to you by
shopify shopify is one of my favorite
companies out there one of my favorite
platforms ever
and let's get into it shopify is a
platform as i mentioned designed for
anyone to sell anything anywhere giving
entrepreneurs the resources once
reserved for big business so what does
that mean that means in no time flat you
can have a great looking online store
that brings your ideas products and so
on to life and you can have the tools to
manage your day-to-day business and
drive sales this is all possible without
any coding or design experience
whatsoever shopify instantly lets you
accept all major payment methods shopify
is thousands of integrations and
third-party apps from on-demand printing
to accounting to advanced chat bots
anything you can imagine
they probably have a way to plug and
play and make it happen shopify is what
i wish i had had when i was venturing
into e-commerce way back in the early
2000s what they've done is pretty
remarkable i first met the founder toby
in 2008 when i became an advisor and
it's been spectacular i've loved
watching shopify go from roughly 10 to
15 employees at the time to 7 000 plus
today serving customers in 175 countries
with total sales on the platform
exceeding 400 billion dollars what does
that really that means every 28 seconds
more or less a small business owner
makes their first sale on shopify more
people in more places of all ages every
single day they power millions of
entrepreneurs from their first sale all
the way to full scale and you would
recognize a lot of large companies that
also use them who started small so get
started by building and customizing your
online store again with no coding or
design experience required access
powerful tools to help you find
customers drive sales and manage your
day-to-day gain knowledge and confidence
with extensive resources to help you
succeed and i've actually been involved
with some of that way back in the day
which was awesome the build a business
competition and other things plus with
24 7 support you're never alone and
let's face it being an entrepreneur can
be lonely but you have support you have
resources you don't need to feel alone
in this case more than a store shopify
grows with you and they never stop
innovating providing more and more tools
to make your business better and your
life easier go to shopify.com
tim that's s-h-o-p
dot com slash tim all lowercase for a
free 14-day trial and get full access to
shopify's entire suite of features start
selling on shopify today go to
shopify.com
tim right now and check it out they have
a lot to offer shopify.com
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance i recommended it
in fact in the 4 hour body this is more
than 10 years ago and i did not get paid
to do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula on the market it
has multi-vitamins multi-mineral greens
complex probiotics and prebiotics for
gut health and immunity formula
digestive enzymes adaptogens and much
more i usually take it once or twice a
day just to make sure i've covered my
bases if i miss anything i'm not aware
of of course i focus on nutrient-dense
meals to begin with that's the basis but
athletic greens makes it easy to get a
lot of nutrition when whole foods aren't
readily available from travel packets i
always have them in my bag when i'm
zipping around right now athletic greens
is giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
[Applause]
you